i feel guilty to begin with you know
because i'm the reason they're going
through this and
even though i'm imprisoned and as far as
i know they're not at the moment in
prison
i feel guilty for what i put them
through when i first heard about this
my mom told me i spoke to her on the
phone i was surprised to be honest
and he has two 60 year old atheists
being convicted for islamic terrorism
doesn't really make much sense
uh given the fact that they actually
sent me money for me to leave isis in
where i was anyway the territories i was
in they sent me money to leave at the
time actually i needed a lot of things i
had no money i was living on the street
or something again i was pretty much i
was living between friends houses and
i didn't have a house actually so they
sent me money to
rent a house and at the time i had to
buy glasses i know it sounds a bit
stupid
i had to buy glasses and you need very
basic any essential things
i really want to see them any more than
i've ever wanted to see them in my whole
life and
being more than two years not being able
to hear my like i said my mother's voice
is
sort of a big deal for us we were very
close family and it's
my mum was my best friend even not just
my mom i know it sounds a bit weirdly
emotional but it's true and
the british people like i said they're
my people but i'm not sure they'd agree
with that
but i have no intention of blowing them
up
that's probably important